okay so yesterday aoc went on her
instagram
sorry the honorable representative
alexander ocasio-cortez d-twitch
she went on her instagram which is the
place to make very serious
allegations instagram and she talked
about her experiences during the day
there are a couple controversial things
that she said in here
let me start with what is
uncontroversial it is it has got to be a
horrifying experience if you're a member
of congress you are rushed
out of your office to an alternative
site because rioters have stormed the
capitol
so i'm not going to doubt that she was
freaked out
and the the one part of the story that's
a little bit humorous is that she
apparently she landed
in the office of representative katie
porter and and she said that katie
porter was sitting there sipping coffee
uh and basically waiting for all of it
to end so kudos to katie porter in any
case
uh aoc describes those experiences but
then
she goes on to to do a couple of things
that are
pretty unpleasant one is that she
suggests that when a capital police
officer arrived in her office to warn
her to go to someplace else now the
writers never actually got into her
office
to be clear a capital police officer
arrived in her office and told her that
she needed to rush out of her office and
get to someplace safer
when the capitol police officer arrived
she suggested that she had doubts
whether he was actually a capital police
officer
because he was flustered and because he
was white
and that was something that she said
which i mean again
i don't think now is the time to
actually be like crapping all over the
capitol police who are
doing their jobs and protecting members
of congress but i guess that um
it is not foreign to democrats
unfortunately to crap all over the
police at every available opportunity in
any case
uh aoc talks about that but the parts
again that are legit when she talks
about being scared and traumatized
i've been in the middle of uh difficult
situations not to this extent obviously
but i've been in the
center of situations where i'm speaking
and we require 600 police officers in
order to guard my speech at berkeley
or i've been in the middle of a quasi
riot like a small-scale riot
over to cal state los angeles where we
required police officers we were banging
on the doors
it's not pleasant it's not pla and this
must have been way more unpleasant than
that i mean this must have been truly
scary obviously i mean there were people
there
who were bang for blood and injuring
police officers so i mean this is way
worse than anything i've ever had to
experience so i don't doubt
that her trauma and experiences are real
here where she goes next that's where i
have some problems so here's what
alexander ocasio-cortez had to say on
her
on her stream last night these folks who
tell us
to move on that it's not a big deal that
we should forget what's happened
or even telling us to apologize
um these are the same tactics of abusers
and um
[Music]
i'm a survivor of sexual assault
um and i haven't told many people that
in my life
um but
when we go through trauma
trauma compounds on each other
okay so a couple of things one sexual
assault is something that ought to be
treated
with the utmost utmost seriousness the
utmost care when people talk about
sexual assault it should not be done
cavalierly
sexual assault i'm not suggesting that
she's talking about her own sexual
assault cavalierly there i don't think
she is
okay sexual assault is in my opinion the
worst crime a human being can commit
against another human being i've long
suggested that rape should be punishable
by death
i think it is a worse crime in many
cases than murder rape is just
a horrific horrific thing obviously so
two things can be true
at once as always one sexual assault is
a grave
grave matter a supremely grave matter
the gravest crime one person can commit
on another person
second to compare sexual assault
to people you disagree with politically
saying
that impeachment is unnecessary at this
point for a person
who did not actually participate in the
capital riots trump
that is an injustice it's an injustice
okay the the the suggestion that what
the people she was talking about there
were ted cruz and josh halley the
senators
who have both suggested that we should
move on in terms of impeachment
right not that we should forget what
happened on january 6 not that the
criminals of january 6
shouldn't be punished but that
impeaching trump at this point he's
already out of office
so there's constitutional questions
there or linking him directly via
modes of incitement to the activity at
the capitol building that the evidence
isn't there for that
to compare those people to rapists which
is what she's doing right there
that's that's an ugly thing to do it's a
really really ugly thing to do
and you you're not granted unlimited
license to compare people
to your sexual assault or because you
have suffered a sexual assault
okay that the the person who is
comparable to the sexual assault or is
the sexual assaulter who should be in
prison who should be in jail i hope to
god that she goes to the police and
whoever sexually assaulted her
ends up in prison because that's where
they belong at a minimum
but the the attempt to suggest that josh
howley and ted cruz are like abusers who
want you to forget about the abuse
to compare them to people who have
engaged in sexual assault
it's truly extraordinary and this is
coming from the same congresswoman who
in the past week has suggested that ted
cruz tried to have her murdered
without evidence which is again normally
when you allege that somebody is an
accessory to murder you ought to have
some evidence to that effect otherwise
this makes you a false witness
there are biblical commandments against
such things so what is the actual goal
here the actual goal here is to mine
anyone
who you disagree with politically or
disagrees with you on impeachment
as not only complicit in that but
complicit in the worst crimes available
to humankind
and that's really inappropriate stuff
come from from a
sitting congress person that again that
is not to undercut anything that she
says about the trauma she experienced
during the day that is not to undercut
anything that she has said about the
trauma of her experience as a sexual
assault survivor
it is to suggest that you don't get to
compare people to sexual assaulters
without evidence that they have
committed sexual assault the worst crime
you can commit against another human
being and you certainly don't get to do
it on the basis that they disagree with
you
about impeachment of a person who's
already out of office and who
in my opinion didn't commit an
impeachable offense anyway in using
inflammatory inappropriate and ugly
language
i mean if the new standard is that if
you use inflammatory ugly language
in order to quote unquote incite and
uprising and alexander ocasio-cortez has
some explaining to do here is
aoc justifying black lives matter
violence during the summer here i mean
again i don't think that she should be
impeached from congress for this
here is alexander ocasio-cortez uh doing
this
again during the summer a little bit of
a flashback here if you're trying to
call for the end of unrest
but you don't believe health care is a
human right if you're afraid to say
black lives matter
if you don't if you're too scared
to call out police brutality then you
aren't asking for an end of
unrest you are asking for injustice to
continue
and for your people to continue to
endure the violence of poverty
the violence of a lack of housing access
the violence of police brutality
and not say a damn thing that's what
you're asking for
okay so again there she was using logic
during the summer basically suggesting
that if you're not calling for universal
health care
then you ought to just be okay with the
riots that were happening during the
summer i mean
that's as inflammatory as anything that
trump said in the lead up to january 6th
so if the goal here in an impeachment
trial is to demonstrate
causality if the goal on an impeachment
trial is to demonstrate actual
incitement
you're going to have to do better than
than what trump did on january 6
and so that's why my deep suspicion here
is that for democrats this is all a pr
mover i mean joe biden has basically
said that joe biden has said
that he understands that there is not
going to be a conviction here that
essentially this is all about just
brow beating republicans who didn't have
anything to do with january 6th
and many of whom were in the same exact
rooms as democrats waiting to be preyed
upon
and and lumping all of those people in
and and you wonder
why republicans are again suspicious of
impeachment it's because of exactly
this type of move facts don't care about
your feelings and it's a fact that the
ben shapiro show is the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content